[Musique]
vous avez une petite baisse d'énergie on
se dit que red bull a monster ou un
gourou ça ferait pas de tort
ça me permet de regarder de go le jeu
c'est petit boost ne sont pas
inoffensifs
en fait dans certains cas ça peut même
tuer qui peuvent être dangereux vraiment
elle si la mort ne peut pas être
beaucoup plus grave que ça et quand on
essaie d'obtenir des réponses auprès des
fabricants de ces produits
c'est souvent très compliqué ici marie
maude denis
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
il était tellement un bon athlète
il est fait et être physiquement
excellent vous avez été appelé et il
était inconscient il était inconscient
il ne respirait plus
l'hypothèse est assez simple ça augmente
la tension artérielle
ça augmente la fréquence cardiaque ça
perturbe le sommeil et ça joue sur la
fonction du cas c'est comme l'alcool ça
tu produis mon portable non sans peine
dans certaines circonstances ça peut
tuer demain je vais regretter asseoir
une pointure et jay avec quelqu'un dans
ton van cau je ne veux pas qu'une autre
famille fuit parce que nous avons
traversée alors est ce qu on attend qu
est de plus en plus de décès ou est-ce
qu'on agit non
[Musique]
les eaux paisibles du lac-saint-pierre
cache un drame c'est ici lever ou 2016
que le fils de rld mitchum est mort il
est venu ce bacille aimé cet endroit
j'ai adoré c'est un endroit zac c'est
son garçon zachary mitchell et ce plan
d'eau situé à 70 kilomètres d'ottawa
c'était son terrain de jeu chaque fois
qu'il est venu pendant le dernier essai
dernière 4-1 et sauter au moins 150 fois
dans l'eau juste ici zachary mezzo 21
ans était un jeune plein d'énergie est
en excellente santé physique selon la
coroner qui a étudié son dossier il
affectionnait particulièrement les
sports acrobatiques
cette vidéo enregistrée par ses amis le
montre justement lac saint pierre
il est et commence un poisson dans l'eau
mais ce soir là après avoir plongé et
exécuté ce même saut il remonte
brièvement à la surface puis il coule au
fond pour ne jamais remonter aide aux
machos parle pour la première fois la
télévision de cette tragédie et des
graves questions qu'elle soulève
j'ai demandé au coroner comment est-ce
que mon petit poisson a coulé dans l'eau
et se noyer
j'avais besoin de la vérité c'est la
coronaire pascale boulay qui est chargée
de faire la lumière sur cette mort
tragique
intrigués et déterminée elle décide
d'aller au bout de cette affaire
zachary avait pris un peu d'alcool mais
conclure à une mort par noyade lui
apparaît comme une réponse incomplète y
est à point toxiques et donc je peux pas
dire que c'est parce que sombrer il tape
moins toxiques et que personne qui a
donné un coup
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il sait nager
il connaît les lieux il était revenu à
la surface donc les pauvres tombé à
quelque part une autre ville
un autre cas la mort du fils de jim
shepherd à toronto semblait elle aussi
inexplicable lorsqu'elle est survenu
devant l'arbre planté à sa mémoire
il se rappelle comment son garçon de 15
ans est mort sans qu'il n'y ait eu aucun
signe annonciateur
brian shepherd était un sportif
les trophées de ses multiples années
walk est décors toujours sa chambre
le 6 janvier 2008
brian venait de participer à un tournoi
de paintball
avec des amis comme il l'avait souvent
fait par le passé ce jour là tout a
basculé
ils attendaient la remise des médailles
lorsqu'il s'est effondré et il a été
conduit à l'hôpital ils l'ont conduit à
l'hôpital
ils ont essayé pendant quatre heures de
corriger la technique mais son coeur a
finalement lâché james shepherd ne
comprend pas comment son fils a pu
mourir
trois mois après sa mort il retourne sur
les lieux de la tragédie
j'ai dit au propriétaire
je ne comprends pas la seule chose
qu'ils ont trouvé dans son système et de
la caféine et il n'en buvaient pas
c'est là qu'il m'a dit je pensais que tu
savais j'ai dit je pensais que je savais
quoi
c'est là que j'ai su que red bull était
passé ce jour là il y avait distribué
des boissons énergisantes
quelqu'un a vu brin prendre une et la
broye sont fait ça but des red bull
pour jim c'est un fait nouveau deux
histoires un point commun les boissons
énergisantes en cours d' enquête la
coronaire pascale boulay apprend que
zachary mitchell a lui aussi été vu avec
ce type de produit juste avant de mourir
il est le seul qui est arrivé avec red
bull et en ont trouvé quatre dents
poubelle
le taux de caféine est compatible avec
le ton qui ont été consommés jeudi qu'il
y en a au moins consommé 2 la coroner
découvre que zachary était porteur d'un
jeune qui le prédisposait à avoir une
arythmie cardiaque
zachary ligne aurait complètement
l'arythmie se serait déclenchée en
combinant l'exercice et le red bull tout
la preuve appuyé le fait que les
boissons énergisantes ont quand même
contribué
elles ne sont pas la cause du décès mais
elles ont contribué à une heure et demie
et le fait que zachary était dans l'eau
des lots de sombrer il s'est noyé
j'ai toujours soupçonné que la boisson
énergisante avait causé la mort de mon
fils je ne peux pas le prouver mais mon
coeur me dit que c'est la seule chose
différente qui est arrivé cette journée
comparativement toutes les autres
journées de sa vie très active
je pense que cette boisson à contribuer
à la mort de mon fils a si elles n'ont
même pas été l'unique cause
quand on parle de boissons énergisantes
on ne parle ni des boissons sportives
pour se réhydrater et qui contiennent
des électrolytes ni des boissons sucrées
alcoolisées comme celles qui ont défrayé
les manchettes
on parle de boissons sucrées qui
contiennent de la caféine en plus
d'autres stimulants comme le guarana les
quines ac ou la taurine c'est ce
qu'avait but zacharie et brian juste
avant de mourir
est-ce que leurs histoires sont des
exceptions
les décès sont certainement des cas
extrêmes mais les effets indésirables
liés à ces produits font l'objet de plus
en plus de recherches
dv damon un chercheur de l'université de
waterloo en ontario a publié
une des études les plus récentes au
canada sur la question près de la moitié
des personnes qui avaient déjà essayé
des boissons énergisantes affirmé avoir
ressenti un effet indésirable allant de
léger à graves comme des palpitations
des nausées des vomissements et
plusieurs cas de combustion au canada
impossible de savoir s'il ya eu des
hospitalisations liées aux boissons
énergisantes mais nous avons découvert
que les centres antipoison eu notre les
appels pour des réactions et piquant
s'est produit pour la première fois nous
avons fait l'exercice de compiler ces
appels à l'échelle du pays
cette province nous ont répondu nos
chiffres montrent que chaque année plus
d'une centaine de canadiens appelle les
centres antipoison pour des cas liés aux
boissons énergisantes
au total depuis 2012 il y a eu plus de
900 appels c'est certain que les appels
au centre antipoison document pas
l'ensemble des expositions évidemment
faux seins ou connaître plus de nous
appeler bien évidemment est ce que c'est
possible qu'on n'est qu'un aperçu de ce
qui se passe réellement dans la
consommation
oui c'est passé pour avoir des gens qui
ont des réactions diverses qui nous ont
pas contactés ça c'est tout à fait
possible
aux etats-unis le nombre de visites aux
urgences liées aux boissons énergisantes
a doublé de 2007 à 2011 passant de 10000
à 20000 par année
mais qu'est ce qui cause ces effets
indésirables la question est encore une
énigme pour les chercheurs après la
pause
un cocktail de stimulant aux effets
indésirables si cette interaction lors
des produits qui vous préoccupe oui par
l'interaction est ce que al additionne
ou à multiplient chez pro c'est ce que
vous voulez savoir john
[Musique]
ils sont dans la jeune vingtaine est en
pleine forme du type à s'entraîner
quotidiennement
pourtant dans les prochaines minutes
l'un d'eux va découvrir que les boissons
énergisantes ne sont pas aussi
inoffensive qu'elles peuvent le paraître
jérémy 20 ans katherine 21 ans et
nicolas 23 ans
non non jamais vu pendant les quatre
prochaines heures ils vont consommer une
canette de boisson énergisante à l'heure
pour résoudre à la bourse aucun but
mettez vous dans votre annonce pour le
jules stade points juge le docteur paul
poirier et le chercheur patrice brassard
avait fait une expérience similaire avec
quatre sujets en 2012
une recherche préliminaire pour obtenir
du financement
on vous l'a juste démontrer comment ça
marche puis commence à perturber le
sommeil puis commence à perturber la
variabilité cardiaque comment le système
cardiaque c'est ça jure c'est un études
de mécanique pour dire écoutez leur
faudrait peut-être que ça soit plus
surveillé que ce soit lyon et bien que
ça soit du gender que ce soin de la
guarana que ce soit de la ta rennes qui
nous a nommé une tranchée il a mais ça
c'est tout dit stimulant donc c'est un
effet additif ou même multiplicateur à
la caf et c'est cette interaction lors
des produits qui vous préoccupe ah oui
par l'interaction est ce que mule à
l'addition ou à multiplient chevaux se
sent qu'on voulait savoir
dès la première canette la pression
artérielle des trois étudiants à
augmenter catherine récent un malaise
chanter que sa demande ait un petit peu
je me suis levée et puis je suis arrivé
hors de l'eau après deux boissons son
malaise persiste à la 3è et 4è canettes
il ne fait qu'empirer la situation
acer est ce qu est ce que ça te fait
comment te décrirais je répondrai que ce
manque 1 et secourisme et comme promis
les résultats de la recherche
préliminaire en 2012 montrait une
tendance les sujets avaient été testées
avec deux red bull et du gourou dans les
deux cas leur tension artérielle avait
augmenté et leur sommeil avait été
perturbé après 4 consommation 3,4 oui
c'est beaucoup mais c'est quand même pas
une quantité industrielle
on voit des résultats on voit d un effet
stimulant qui est quand même important
donc soit on est prédisposé il s'agit
d'avoir un petite étincelle pour pour
toutes parts
la compagnie québécoise gourou a voulu
réagir aux résultats se faire attention
va tirer des conclusions sur une étude
avec quatre personnes qui est plus une
étude pour confirmer un protocole de
recherche dans le but d'obtenir du
financement pour faire un long trajet
est ce qu'il ya un potentiel de
dangerosité
j'imagine comme n'importe quel n'importe
quel ingrédient d'endicott d'abus je
pense que pour avoir un potentiel de
danger
gourou qui veut se distinguer des géants
de l'industrie avec sa boisson certifiés
bio n'est pas surpris des résultats
m'ont dit pas qu'un gourou et moins
stimulant car gbagbo ont dit pas qu'un
gourou à moins de caféine que red bull
ont dit qu'un gourou c'est beaucoup plus
simple pour la santé car est beau donc
si vous voulez comparer les deux
produits on peut comparer une courte
liste de plantes naturelles et bio
versus une longue liste d'ingrédients
artificiels nos cobayes ont pris des
boissons pendant une seule journée
le docteur poirier se préoccupe aussi de
ce qui se passe quand on en prend
régulièrement nous on a un code une
jeune femme de 26 ans sera mort c'est
avec un coeur mécanique puis en attente
d'une greffe cardiaque parce qu'à
consommer des boissons de son histoire
qu'il connaît bien a défrayé les
manchettes à québec
la jeune femme a été traitée par un de
ses confrères
un cas qui démontre ce qui peut arriver
quand on consomme comme dans notre
expérience au moins quatre boissons par
jour mais tous les jours c'est de
constituer avec dataflux avec d'autres
produits qui peuvent être de l'état si
c'est plus un trou dans triste et
dangereuse élémentaire jeu de la mort ne
peut pas être beaucoup plus grave que
soldat décédé
j'ignorais tout des boissons
énergisantes quelque chose avait tué mon
fils et je ne savais même pas ce que
c'était après la mort de son fils james
shepherd a senti le besoin de comprendre
et d'agir
il se met à sensibiliser les politiciens
et la population sur les dangers liés à
la consommation de ces produits
lorsque je racontais l'histoire de bryan
les gens me disaient j'ai essayé ces
boissons jeunes en reprendrait jamais je
répondais avez vous signaler l'incident
santé canada dans tous les cas sauf un
et je parle de 40 à 50 personnes
la réponse était non james shepherd lui
a signalé à santé canada que son fils
était décédé après avoir consommé une
boisson énergisante
cette information était disponible à
tous les canadiens sur internet sur un
site qui s'appelle canada vigilance de
2003 à 2013 143 effets indésirables
certains impliquant des enfants aussi
jeunes que huit ans ont été ainsi rendus
publics incluant trois morts sow est
l'un des trois décès d'adolescents
répertoriés dans la base de données de
santé canada c'est très important que ce
soit documenté à quel point c'était
important pour vous là c'est ce qui
s'appelle de la transparence
à l'époque c'était très transparent plus
de problèmes cardiaques chez des
adolescents liés aux boissons
énergisantes était signalé que pour tous
les autres médicaments en vente libre
réunis il se passe c'est clairement
quelque chose qu'il fallait examiner
davantage
c'est notamment pour cette raison que
santé canada réuni un comité d'experts
en 2010 leur rapport de 18
recommandations et sans équivoque
ils recommandent en priorité de ne pas
laisser ces produits en vente libre et
de les traiter comme des médicaments pas
comme de simples aliments le
gouvernement conservateur fait
exactement le contraire
en réponse à l'avis des experts santé
canada a fait sa propre étude
c'est cette étude qui justifiera la
position prise par le gouvernement
joint au téléphone le directeur à
l'époque de la direction des aliments de
santé canada samuel godefroy aussi
coauteur de l'étude continue de croire
que c'était la chose à faire
malgré les effets indésirables
répertoriés en 4 1 milliards de
consommation
l'opposition dénonce la décision du
gouvernement de la santé suisse en droit
de tout poil à l'encontre de l'un d'eux
la vie de son ex elle vous met ses
marchés nous sommes en 2019 et les
boissons énergisantes sont toujours en
vente libre et les producteurs payent
pour avoir une bonne visibilité
c'est pourquoi exemple paul leur
frigidaire là et ont donc choses près du
prêt-à-manger ou si c'est ce qui impose
comme condition pour avoir
puis valable même si depuis la réforme
santé canada plafonne le contenu de
caféine à 180 mg par canette et qu'on
exige des fabricants qu'ils mettent des
avertissements les ventes ont explosé 2
milliards 200 millions de canettes se
sont vendus depuis le changement de
réglementation jusqu'en 2017
au départ on en a fait preuve de
fraîcheur comme ça on avait un petit
coin
plus reculer un peu mais ça tellement
fine ampleur au fur et à mesure des
années quant aux doigts de mettre en
évidence les produits
mais les problèmes de santé liés aux
boissons énergisantes eux sont loin
d'être mises en évidence
en fait ils sont maintenant caché par le
gouvernement depuis la réforme de 2013
santé canada n'a plus à publier les
effets indésirables liés à ces produits
sur le site canada vigilance et c'est
l'industrie qui est tenu de les signaler
au gouvernement donc si un consommateur
de red bull par exemple éprouve un effet
indésirable
c'est à red bull qu'il doit le signaler
et c'est la compagnie qui doit le
déclarer au gouvernement c'est à dire
soto dénoncé sur la canette il n'y a pas
de site web ou que des formations
nous avons tenté l'expérience avec james
shepherd des déclaré un effet
indésirable directement à red bull
au fond il n'y a pas de numéro de
téléphone il faut écrire un courriel
donc aucun nom de qui que ce soit qui
vous pourriez parler passe au stade
c'est sûr nous avons demandé aux plus
importants fabricants de nous dire
combien ils ont déclaré d'incidents
depuis 2012 aucun n'a voulu nous
répondre
sauve gourou qui dit n'avoir reçu aucun
signalement d'effets indésirables
le consommateur se demandaient s'ils
étaient allergiques qui va plus mal à la
gorge pour ça que je suis très très très
confiants vous devez connaître produits
sécuritaires on parle de plus de 100
millions de km dans les cinq dernières
années
quant à santé canada il nous aura fallu
six mois pour qu'on nous réponde que de
2012 à 2017
il y a eu 87 incidents de gravité
variable
santé canada admet avoir reçu quatre
signalements de décès depuis 2012 qui
s'ajoute aux trois déjà connu mais on
refuse de nous accorder une entrevue
n'est pas parce que on n'en parle pas
que papa et maman parce que la phase 1
de l'urgence des gens qui font les
médecins qui font d'urgence qui vont
vous devez disparaître pas demain matin
dans la suite de notre enquête crée des
événements pour distribuer des boissons
gratuitement alors que ce n'est pas
permis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
23 mai ghani à montréal le red boys pit
stop challenge bat son plein impossible
pour les passants de le manquer vous ne
connaissez pas l'événement c'est normal
il s'agit d'une pure création de red
bull les étudiants de l'école de
technologie supérieure s'affrontent dans
une simulation d'arrêt aux puits des
consommateurs de red bull ici il y en a
la boisson populaire sur le campus
surtout que la compagnie ne se gêne pas
pour en donner
on note très très très très tôt commencé
à distribuer les produits sur lesquels
peu short comme ce le début la première
fois forcément j'étais sur ses campus là
et le professeur en marketing jacques
nantel enseigné à vienne en autriche
pays où red bull a vu le jour en 1987 à
pratiquer tourne autour d'aliens on a
tous du show au moins une fois dans la
vie mais autour d'un produit qui
conseille pas d'alcool ça c'était assez
assez basse est totalement nouveau
vellev manoeuvre
aguédé avec moi
créer des événements c'est la spécialité
de red bull
l'entreprise autrichienne est partout du
vélo au ski en passant par les plongeons
les compétitions de riz propre les
courses à passer jusqu'au saut à partir
de lesparre la recette a été si efficace
qu'elle a été reprise par pratiquement
tous les concurrents aujourd'hui ils ont
tous leur propre série d'événements et
s'en servent pour faire la promotion de
leurs produits
une étude canadienne récente révèle que
chez les 12 à 14 ans quarante deux pour
cent se croit ciblés par ces publicités
et pense qu'elle s'adresse peut-être à
de plus jeunes encore autrement dit la
publicité est particulièrement efficace
chez les adolescents c'est sûr que le
fait que ce soit un produit qui soit à
ceux ci a dû par extrême à des
événements extrêmes qui est un emballage
et des couleurs qui sont très très très
jeunes du dessin qui est très jeune ça
peut pas faire autrement
l'auteur de l'étude pensent que ces
stratégies publicitaires ne sont pas
innocentes
eide je ne crois pas qu'il y ait
beaucoup d'adultes comme moi qui font du
bmx
j'ai déjà demandé un représentant des
compagnies de me dire sans rire que
leurs publicités n'attire pas les
enfants il a eu le culot de me dire sans
rire que ce n'était pas le cas mais je
pense que nous rechercher le gros bon
sens suggère le contraire aux james
shepherd recense depuis des années les
exemples où il considère que les enfants
en bas âge sont visés par des publicités
il alerte les autorités pour qu'elles
interviennent que ce soit intentionnel
ou par accident
ils ne respectent pas la réglementation
au canada il est interdit de cibler les
enfants dans la publicité de boissons
énergisantes
il est aussi interdit de laisser
entendre implicitement ou explicitement
que ces boissons améliore les
performances physiques
l'association québécoise des médecins du
sport est préoccupée par ce qu'elle voit
ce produit qui devrait pas être vu par
les enfants et les adolescents
et malheureusement c'est le grand public
cible c'est ceux qui en boivent le plus
c'est ceux qui sont le plus sensibles
aux effets néfastes et en plus souvent
et les bois dans un contexte justement
d'activités sportives
nos données suggèrent que certaines
choses vont à l'encontre de la
réglementation ou à tout le moins de
l'esprit du règlement relation de retour
à montréal au pit stop challenge
red bull avait pris des engagements avec
l'école de technologie supérieure la
consommation fils et à consommation jeu
sur les gens qui partent à l'événement
dekel et les informations lui est bon
pour les donner un jeu saw gens qui
participent à l'événement mais sur place
devant notre caméra red bull est
carrément délais quand les personnels
distribuer allègrement ses produits
gratuitement sans égard à ce qui a été
convenu même des touristes de passage
sans free nous tentons d'obtenir des
explications de red bull
l'artiste
[Musique]
mais ce n'est pas si simple quand on
demande une entrevue à red bull
l'entreprise affirme qu'elle n'a aucun
porte-parole au canada la totalité de
leurs événements ce sont leurs
événements c'est leur monde à chaque et
les mains de leur monde il le contrôle
[Musique]
au retour notre équipe fait une
incursion chez red bull
[Musique]
à défaut de pouvoir trouver un porte
parole chez red bull nous décidons nous
rendre au siège social canadien de
l'entreprise à toronto jim shepherd nous
accompagne lui aussi a tenté de joints
de red bull pour leur parler de son fils
sans succès sur le site de l'entreprise
il n'y a ni numéro de téléphone ni
adresse d'estoril will be nous avons une
adresse retrouvée dans le registre de
lobbying du canada
sur une rue commerciale du centre-ville
aucune enseigne aucune trace du taureau
pourtant si visible dans les publicités
avec la géolocalisation du téléphone
intelligent nous conduisent dans un
stationnement
ok
un travailleur dans un local voisin nous
oriente vers une porte anonymes qui nous
avait échappé clairement en avançant
nous sommes au bon endroit
à l'intérieur la décoration des bureaux
est branché ça bourdonne d'activités
la directrice des communications arrive
à radio canada même avec la directrice
des communications de red bull canada
il ne semble y avoir qu'une obsession
lorsqu'on pose des questions évitez la
caméra
ok
préfère la caméra la suite de la
discussion se fera à caméra fermés dans
le corridor
alors qu'est ce qu'elle vous a dit après
qu'on ait dû arrêter de tourner elle m'a
dit que je pouvais les contacts et son
journaliste et qu'il discuterait avec
moi à ce jour contrairement à son
engagement
red bull n'a jamais pris contact avec
jim shepherd est pas refusé nos demandes
d'entrevue à la caméra la compagnie
réfère toute communication à l'organisme
qui s'occupe du lobby pour l'ensemble de
l'industrie
l'association canadienne des boissons
l'association a également décliné nos
demandes d'entrevue
tout en soutenant que ces produits sont
sécuritaires
adam et show n'était pas à l'aise de
s'adresser à red bull pour signaler les
circonstances tragiques du décès de son
fils elle a donc essayé de le faire
auprès de l'agencé canadienne
d'inspection des aliments qui est devenu
le seul point de chute gouvernementale
pour les consommateurs fait pas trouvé
le moyen de tulle sont sur leur site web
commandeur apporter mes préoccupations
même après les conclusions l'impé de du
rapport de la coroner tout ce qu'elle a
reçue est un accusé de réception avec
eux résumé de la mission de lagence et
ça ne nous est pas non plus qu'ils
allaient tenir compte de la mort de
zacharie qu'ils allaient investir
davantage qu'ils allaient faire la
prévention rien rien qu'une organisation
financée par des fonds publics qui
assimile employés n'est pas le temps de
faire le suivi après le signalement de
décès me semble hautement problématique
mais l'avocat bill jeffery spécialisé en
politique alimentaire a tenté de savoir
qu'est ce qui se passe quand l'agencé
canadienne d'inspection des aliments
reçoit une déclaration d'incident comme
celui de karim est chaud comme nous il a
dû faire une demande d'accès à
l'information
dans un échange particulièrement
troublant de plusieurs courriels à la
suite de signalements de décès les
fonctionnaires de lagence s'interroge
sur la nécessité d'informer santé canada
ça révèle un très faible niveau de
curiosité et un empressement à faire
mais c'est aussi comme si c'était des
tas de choses après plusieurs jours de
discussions
une fonctionnaire fini par conclure
comme c'est le fabricant qui doit
rapporter tout incident de consommation
à santé canada dans le cadre d'un
rapport annuel
l'agencé canadienne d'inspection des
aliments n'a pas besoin de rapporter ces
incidents à santé canada
autrement dit les organismes n'ont
aucune obligation de se parler entre eux
just jared
je me disais c'est un décès ne
devrait-il pas s'assurer que santé
canada est au courant sur un an après la
pause on vous amène dans des après bâle
où on fait des mélanges explosifs
[Musique]
l'après bal c'est la fête qui marque la
fin du secondaire
la tradition veut que ça se passe dans
un camping c'est le moment de tous les
excès en juin dernier nous avons été une
des rares équipes de télévision à
pouvoir filmer la majorité ces jeunes
n'ont même pas l'âge légal pour
consommer de l'alcool mais l'occasion
est spécial et parce qu'elle l'est il
faut aussi tenir le coup toute la soirée
toute la nuit pourquoi tu apprends
maintenant chaque fascicule viager bruce
est ok je voudrais saluer avec cascades
entend vraiment ça me permet de regarder
on a un gros de gros debout
cette époque avec personne le mélange de
l'alcool et des boissons énergisantes et
suffisamment dangereux pour que santé
canada exige une mention sur la canette
ne pas mélanger avec l'alcool d'après
toi est ce que jean la moitié de mon
annonce au monde
je pense que la moitié on a au moins la
moitié ok pas facile d'encadrer la
consommation de ces boissons
à preuve beaucoup de ces après bâle ont
lieu à radio dans la région de
lanaudière
pourtant radenne fait partie d'une
soixantaine de villes municipalités et
mrc qui interdisent les boissons
énergisantes mais c'est un geste presque
symbolique dans nos édifices municipaux
on en a pas si on engage quelqu'un on
lui défendant vente si on donne une
concession à un endroit il peut
commencer c'est là qu'est ce que je peux
gérer le geste que je peux gérer ça
n'empêche pas les dépanneurs et les
épiceries de la ville d'en vendre et pas
besoin d'attendre longtemps pour trouver
des consommateurs c'est quoi cette
demande sans tâche des apprentis va
pourquoi par semaine je dirais c'est du
red bull alors est-ce qu'on atteint qui
est de plus en plus de décès ou est-ce
qu'on agit maintenant
alors quoi faire plusieurs croient que
c'est la publicité qui doit être plus
strictement réglementée surtout que
l'industrie a tendance à mettre en scène
ses produits dans les situations de
consommation les plus dangereuses
est-ce qu'on demanderait à mons une de
financer la maison jean lapointe pense
pas moins
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on permet
d'associer un produit qu'on sait qu'il
peut mener à une heure et demie dans des
pratiques sportives
ben là est-ce que c'est seulement les
intérêts économiques qui prennent moi je
me pose la question
c'est sûr que ça s'adresse aux sportifs
parce que le marketing est vraiment
diriger vers le sport il ya beaucoup
d'athlètes qui sont commandités par les
boissons énergisantes en tant que
médecin qui courbe des athlètes et des
compétitions sportives c'est quelque
chose qui nous inquiète on veut pas de
mort subite on veut pas d'eux
d'accidents tragiques
si vous réglementer un produit un aspect
de voir comment il est mise en marché
est annoncée parce que ces influences
qui consomment le produit et comment il
est consommé mais l'industrie mène un
combat de tous les instants dans tous
les pays du monde
chaque fois qu'on veut limiter la vente
libre de ces produits l'an dernier le
parlement britannique a tenu des
audiences pour interdire la vente aux
moins de 16 ans les députés ont
questionné les experts des fabricants
qui évidemment s'y opposer
l'expert de la compagnie monster que
vous voyez c'est ashley roberts
il travaille pour la firme intertek
c'est cette même firme canadienne qui a
représenté l'industrie du tabac puis
monde vento dans le dossier du
glyphosate au canada intertek était
aussi en campagne de lobbying en 2010 au
moment où s'amorçait le débat sur la
révision de la réglementation des
boissons énergisantes est possible de
savoir qui avait embauché la firme red
bull aussi était très active
la compagnie avait deux lobbyistes à
ottawa elle en a toujours eu depuis
conclu des fabricants l'association
canadienne des boissons mène la charge
dès qu'il est question de resserrer la
réglementation comme ici à toronto où
elle s'oppose à une interdiction de
vendre boissons énergisantes et alcool
au même endroit deux mixes un studio ça
n'a pas de sens que la ville ajoute sa
propre réglementation sur l'étiquetage
le marketing de ces produits en plus des
règles imposées par santé canada
les autorités m'ont raconté qu'elles
n'avaient jamais fait l'objet de
lobbying aussi fort que lorsqu'elles ont
essayé de bannir la vente de boissons
énergisantes aux endroits qui servent
aussi de l'alcool
les compagnies de boissons énergisantes
ont le droit de faire ça et elles le
font très bien a plaidé pour plus de
précaution face à l'industrie mais santé
canada n'a jamais voulu aller aussi loin
que lui c'est ce qui se produit lorsque
vous faites face à une industrie de
plusieurs milliards de dollars
il y a beaucoup de réticences
à remettre en cause l'ordre établi par
le système même si sa cause du tort à
certaines personnes
[Musique]
malheureusement les profits de
l'industrie et son influence sur les
décisions sont tout aussi importants
aujourd'hui qu'avant pour jim shepherd
il est trop tard mais il demeure
convaincu que la seule mesure efficace
c'est l'interdiction aux mineurs
l'industrie dit que ces boissons ne sont
pas pour les enfants
santé canada dit qu'elles ne sont pas
pour les enfants alors pourquoi sont
elles accessibles aux enfants
si c'est pas bon pour le sentais
totalement la réglementation est fait au
niveau de la province beaucoup plus
facile et j'ai beaucoup on nous parle
même gourou n'est pas fermé à l'idée
d'interdire l'achat aux moins de 16 ans
s'y joue un jeune de 16 ans qui
consomment un goût par jour
je trouve pas ça scandaleux plus jeune
que 16 ans je trouve que c'est
inapproprié
pourquoi parce que je pense pas qu'à
cette heure-là on a nécessairement la
maturité pour prendre les décisions pour
soi même
malgré les tentatives de restreindre les
boissons énergisantes
elles sont toujours en vente libre dans
175 pays ça n'implique pas que ces
produits soient sécuritaires ou non ce
chiffre n'a aucune pertinence sont tient
pas compte des visites aux urgences ou
de la mort de zacharie par exemple
alors je pose la question est-ce qu'elle
ne décède zachary michel était évitable
oui je pense que oui il se produit en
vente libre est susceptible d'entraîner
la mort
on devrait en être informé riche d'un
robot
il faut chercher plus loin pour trouver
les statistiques pour faire quelque
chose dit
est de mitchell espère qu'en partageant
son histoire elle permettra aux
canadiens de prendre conscience qu'il
faut davantage de transparence
quand vous voyez le lac aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que comment vous vous sentez
c'est triste mais on ne peut pas ignorer
les morts qui sont devant lui le public
du canada ont le droit à la vérité aussi
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié en quête
de ce soir au nom de toute l'équipe
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là revenez
nous la semaine prochaine pour une autre
enquête
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]